you've announced a review into the use
of oximeters which is which have led to
an underestimate of the treatment needs
of
people of color is that an admission
that our health services have a systemic
undeclared racial bias
you know what there may actually be a
health services across the world a a
systemic uh racial bias i'm sad to say
and this came about because you know
there's lots of health disparities in in
our country there are in many countries
but we saw that i think quite acutely
during the covet crisis if you were from
a bme uh background you were
a third of admissions were from bme
background in in icu units at the height
of the crisis and that compares to
that's more than double the
representation in the population and i
asked my team to look at this in some
detail i wanted to really understand
what was going on and one of the reasons
they came back with with was around
pulse oximeters a medical device that
you know tells you about your oxygen
level crucial with covert and combating
covid and from in many cases it was
giving false readings and you know what
really got me was that this was was this
was already known there are research
papers already on this and no one did
anything about it now i'm not saying
this was deliberate by anyone i think
it's just
it's a systemic issue potentially with
medical devices and it may go even
further than that with medical textbooks
for example and so
that's why i've uh announced today that
this is something i think that we should
do something about not just here in the
uk i want to work with my colleagues
across the world i've already talked to
my counterpart in the u.s and here is as
interested in this as i am and uh and
see what we can do because clearly
something like this can never be
acceptable as you said this is not just
something we've discovered with kobe
this particular thing was known before
uh there's been lots of work which shows
that medical trials which i think you've
mentioned are frankly the the samples
which contain thousands of people are
often racially biased uh
not with not enough people of color in
them and of course
we've had a report from a group of mps
this week uh with about the treatment of
people with sickle cell anemia who are
almost exclusively black
and the deficiencies in that um
bluntly
can frankly people like you and me
really trust that the nhs is going to
treat us fairly
i think we can we can trust the nhs but
i think
of course we can uh
and let's not
the nhs has been there for all of us for
for for decades now and and helped all
every community in britain and that's of
course uh something that is right but we
should always be looking to see what
could be done uh to improve things and
and this particular issue about you know
racial bias in in medical instruments
it's global it's nothing to really i
think it's it's not really about the nhs
it's a it's a global issue these
oxymeters are being used
across the world they all have the same
problem uh some of the other issues
we've come across and you've mentioned
around sickle cell anemia and things
these are global issues and i think
britain is in a place
to take some leadership on this and and
as i say as i've discussed it with my
counterparts there some of them have
been surprised about this about the the
evidence that i've presented them with
but they are all united in wanting to do
something about it and i hope that i'm
in a position over the next few years to
to do more about this and and let
britain take the lead all right this
week we've seen the return of lockdown
across uh europe do we need to prepare
for more restrictions here before
christmas well i think as we all look
forward to christmas it's very sad to
see cases rising you're surging in
certain parts of europe now we've always
known that this virus it loves the
winter it likes the cold darker days
that winter brings and we need to make
sure we're doing everything we can to
protect ourselves against that what's
made a real difference here in the uk is
our booster program our hugely
successful booster program almost 15
million booster jabs given already
covering some quarter of the population
over the age of 12 almost 400 000 a day
across the uk and that's making the
difference and we know that because just
this week there was more data published
after more studies that shows that the
protection you get from your booster the
changing of protection it almost doubles
from 50 percent to over 90 percent and
i'll be extending the booster program
starting tomorrow to 40 to 49 year olds
but you know
all of us we've all got a role to play
in this and in in our national
vaccination program and if you're
eligible for your waste your first shot
second shot or your third shot you'll
please come forward and let's look
forward to christmas together all the
same as one of my australians friends um
said about uh covert 19 just before they
went back into
a huge lockdown this thing is a tricky
bugger shouldn't you be dusting off plan
b
vaccine passport uh requirement for
masks just in case well the first thing
i'd say trevor if i may said you know we
made a a tough decision back in the
start of the summer
other countries didn't follow our course
and we decided that of course we want to
start opening up and if you're going to
do that it's best to do it into summer
it's far safer to do it in summer sadly
other countries in europe did not do
that but looking ahead as we look down
towards winter we need to make sure that
we are remain cautious we are not
complacent in any way i've mentioned the
importance of the booster program but in
terms of any other potential measures
we've said all along we've got plan a
and that's where we firmly are at the
moment if we needed to take further
measures with plan b then we would do so
but we're not at that point yeah but
i suppose
you've pinned all your hopes on the
vaccine
rollout successful booster program going
quite well
but isn't the truth here that this is a
disguised form frankly of herd immunity
either through
vaccines or through natural immunity uh
induced in those who've had covet um
isn't this really still pretty risky
um i i wouldn't i wouldn't accept the
the way you've put it really and if i
may and the reason is because of course
the the vaccines are hugely important
part of our protection against this this
horrible virus but you're beyond that
there's a lot else going on so you
absolutely let it go as far in the hope
that the vaccine would get ahead of the
spread no not at all if you look at what
else that we are doing look at our
testing system uh we have a juggernaut
of a testing system you have more than i
think any other country in europe in
terms of the availability of tests the
type of tests we have a a surveillance
program that is the envy of the world we
have you know have clear guidance out
there we've taken decisions for example
the one i announced last week around uh
nhs uh compulsory vaccinations for
people working the nhs in in your care
staff so
taking together i think these are of
course the right measures but where i
think you would be right of course we
need to remain cautious uh this thing
can be very unpredictable and we need to
be ready and monitor the data extremely
carefully and that's exactly what we do
but cautious relative too i mean even in
in the uk england is an outlier
yesterday at hamdan park uh fans were
required to show that they had been
double jab before they could
get into the stadium today uh man city
are going to play everton 52 000 people
no requirement to show you a double jab
i mean we are taking the risky path but
we we've made a decision in this country
to take a different path in some ways we
don't have
the so-called sort of vaccine passport
if if an operator or a venue operator
wants to take additional measures that's
up to them but i think the package the
balance that we set out in plan a and
then making sure that we've got
contingency measures in place the
so-called plan b i think's been the
right path has been proven to be the
right path i think we can safely say
that so far but as i say we can't be
complacent and can i also mention the
flu jabs the flu jabs are a hugely
important part of our winter plan and
we're seeing record numbers of people
come forward for those as well it's the
biggest flu vaccination program this
country has seen and that's just as
important this winter as covert booster
shots well look you know i
forgive me for banging on about the risk
here but we know what the real issue is
that the nhs will be overwhelmed i'm
going to talk to chris hopson uh the the
boss of nhs providers later and he's
going to tell me that it's it's dire you
yourself have said that waiting lists
could climb as high as 13 million do you
happen to know by the way where we are
on waiting lists this weekend what's the
number
it's 5.9 million roughly involved
people waiting for
elective procedures is around 5.9
million and as i've said i've been
really clear this number is going to go
up before it comes down why because some
seven to eight million people stayed
away during the height of the coveted
crisis because they were asked to they
did what was asked of them but i want
them to come forward i want them to come
back to the nhs i want them to know that
it is open to them and if you take that
along with normal demand of course
that's huge pressure and can i say
you're right to talk about the pressure
on the nhs it is significant and and i
think everyone working the nhs and
certainly from everything i hear
everything i've seen they are doing an
absolutely amazing job and they will get
all the support that we can possibly
provide 5.9 million are you actually
going to wait till we hit 13 million
before you do something like for example
bring the nightingale hospitals back in
well
the 13 million number was if we'd
carried on with business as usual of
course what we've what we've done in the
in the last couple of months has set out
our plans for the longer term not just
this winter but over the longer term
with with the new funding settlement for
the nhs which will allow us to invest
more whether it's in the workforce but
at what number will you decide to do
something like what they're doing in
scotland what they're doing in wales
what they're doing across the continent
to
to arrest the spread of transmission are
you just going to wait now that that
trevor if i say that's more around
winter pressure the elective procedures
back that will take time it's not just a
question over the winter it's going to
take the time after the winter of course
to continue to work through those people
that are waiting for procedures over the
winter in particular that where as we
know you know covid particularly likes
the winter we set out our plan a but
when it comes to winter pressures for
the nhs and where they are significant i
readily accept that is that that's where
we've provided more support an extra 5.4
billion pounds of funding over this
winter for the nhs and for the care
system because they're very
linked
in helping to deal with winter pressures
and that has provided support for
example for more 999 callers 111
ambulance services discharge uh
discharge fund for for people that are
ready to be clinically discharged from
hospital but a care place that can't
easily be found so more funding for that
so all of this is helping and and let me
be clear i'm not pretending for a second
that that this is uh
you're going to take away all the
pressures of the winter of course not we
normally have tough winters and with
kovid it's going to be even harder but i
think the nhs is doing a fantastic job
and we will support them in every way we
possibly can all right let's talk about
another source of pressure on the
government not that you haven't got
enough already but we know that there
have been record numbers of people
landing on the beaches from the
continent this uh this weekend um
in 15 months you were home secretary
we saw fewer than 2 000 a year landing
um
in 2020 that number quadrupled to 8 400
and we know this year it's increased to
24 000. that's ten
ten times the number when you were in
office um would you have tolerated this
uh this kind
of breach of our borders
well the first thing is to say is that
we are seeing a huge rise in irregular
migration across the world including of
course
europe and sadly we're seeing many of
these your people smugglers these
criminals these violent criminals that
are exploiting uh people and what we're
seeing in the channel is is that that
you know that sort of so-called business
model of these smugglers i mean this
this route this 21-mile route across the
channel that this is some of the most
dangerous waters in the world it's one
of the busiest shipping lanes in the
world and no one should be risking their
life across they said it's the people
smugglers that are to blame for this and
it's right that the home secretary is
looking at every option that there is to
try and break this business that's all
true but
the na the words take back control echo
in my head and it seems to me that the
last thing that's happened is that we've
taken back any control in fact we've
handed it over to the people's smugglers
would you have tolerated this number
crossing the channel were you home
secretary well no no one will tolerate
this then when the home sector is set
out how this is of course not she's
doing a huge amount of work in trying to
break this business model so the the
nationality and borders bill that she's
brought in front of parliament now
coming back to the house of commons soon
that is setting out a whole bunch of new
measures and actions we can take and
let's and let's be clear on this trevor
that
people
that are
this country has a great track record
rightly so of providing security and
protection to those people who are
genuinely fleeing persecution and we've
done that recently just with afghanistan
and it has been right to do that but we
do have to ask ourselves is that if
people are trying to get to the uk from
safe countries like france are they
genuine asylum seekers or not and it is
right to ask that and it is right to
change the rules to to to take that into
account and that's what the home
secretary is doing all right one quick
uh last point on this um how the talks
with removing them to albania or rwanda
going i'm not gonna comment in any
speculation nice try i don't think you
expect me to say anything else
all right let's talk about cricket and
race now i assume you'll have followed
like everybody else the dramatic
revelations from yorkshire um
can you empathize with as the azim rafiq
stories are there things in your own
experience that
with which this resonates yes of course
and when i
when i first heard about this and that
was uh when i really looked at it was
when the the i think was a leak of the
report that the the the club had done on
this issue
and it really just shocked me in this in
this day and age that the the people
doing this report would have these views
that somehow being called is banter it's
it's it's not it never has been and uh
and yeah you asked me about personal
experience yeah when i was growing up as
a kid i was cool almost every day at
school i didn't like it then i don't
like it now i think the good news is our
country has come a long long way uh you
know since then but clearly not every
institution in the country has taken
that journey and it's clear to everyone
now that yorkshire county cricket club
is one of those institutions that has
been stuck in the dark ages and needs to
change that process of change i think
with lord patel there has has begun but
there's going to be a long way to go and
the ecb should be doing its job to make
sure that this is
taken seriously throughout cricketing in
the uk
uh just in in passing i noticed that uh
and it's interesting you can use the p
word i obviously cannot
it's an interesting question about how
we deal and talk about these things but
a specific um question really we've been
talking about all of these things and
you and i have talked about it before
cricket football
in politics
when the government uh thought that the
incursions on freedom of speech in
universes getting were getting out of
hand it has intervened there's a new
piece of legislation
don't you think it's time seeing what
we're seeing on football more complaints
on football refugees this morning
daily revelations about cricket isn't it
time for the government essentially to
stop trusting the sporting authorities
the ecb fn all of that who clearly
from what we've seen failed and for the
government to step in in the way it has
done in universities on freedom of
speech well i think it's a very good
question because i think the the
sporting authorities
yeah whether it's football cricket they
they talk the talk but you know what
what have they actually done that's
really helping and you know i remember
when i was the culture secretary and
overseeing your sport in this country i
remember meeting the ecb then about
issues of uh racial discrimination in
cricket and they were telling me what
they're going to do and look where we
are now many years later look at what's
happening look at what's being uncovered
i don't think the ecb has taken this
issue very seriously i think they need
to take a long hard look at themselves
and now this is a real test for them and
uh and let's see if they can pass it and
if they fail that test
then let's wait and see that's going to
be decision for the culture secretary
but i will say this that the culture
secretary the current cold secretary
takes this issue just as seriously as i
do